E aí
[Música]
Oi Josi boa noite valeu Marlei novo Eu
tenho 26 anos sou geminiana geminiana
dinheiro vendendo como quiser levar uma
coisa ao meu respeito eu queria dizer
boa noite
a mesma Barreiro ontem o 26 anos sou
geminiana geminiana geminiana e melhor
vamos fazer alguma coisa Me respeite eu
queria eu queria falar de amor eu vi a
sala de paz eu queria falar de luz eu
queria falar de transformação eu queria
falar de acerto eu queria falar com
saudade eu queria falar de de
tranquilidade eu queria falar de glória
para falar de mim eu queria falar de
amor eu queria falar de paz eu queria
falar de transformação queria falar de
vida eu queria falar da abundância Bem
enroladinho de sete vamos fazer de gozo
é preparado de blog eu queria falar de
nenhuma obrigação de eu quero falar
dinheiro
eu já morri de saudade de afeto de
carinho Boa noite ele vai amar de novo
Eu tenho 26 anos sou geminiana geminiana
de Liliane dizendo que eu quiser já
falou com ele lá no Face eu queria falar
já mole porque essa loja mais lá
e já blá blá blá blá blá blá blá blá blá
blá blá blá blá blá já a baba Maio
E desejando eu tirei aqui quinto eu
desejo tanto não tem mais frango eu
queria todo não tem mais motivo de
espanto eu desejo tanto no não tem mais
frango eu eu queria tanto não sei mais
motivo disso são me desejaram a morte
caçoaram da minha sorte fizeram a minha
estrutura tremer quando eu não soube
dizer quem eu era não conseguiram me
reconheceria por isso que eu
o desejo tanto não tem mais frango Eu
queria tanto não sei mais motivo de raio
eu desejo tanto não demais tanto eu
queria tanto não ser mais motivo desse
plano a minha carteira ninguém assinou
não quiseram saber de mim quando eu
estava com dor a minha carteira ninguém
assim já saber de mim lua arrumou casa
dinheiro emprego desistiram de bons
vazio e o nome só ninguém de mim
E aí
o emprego um desespero de bolso bateu as
botas
E aí
e eu vou me virar é 8 ou 80 se só se
Odeio acordar com arrebenta ouvir
diferente eu não daria certo
me engano errado absurdo promoção do
contra todos vocês tudo certo ou muito
mais tempo que vocês imaginam só pega
realmente eu peguei eu desejo tanto não
tem mais frango eu
eu não sei mais motivo disso tudo Eu
desejo tanto não tem mais Fran tu eu eu
queria tanto você leva surgir
e eu queria falar de amor eu queria
falar de paz eu queria falar de saudade
queria falar dia certo aqui para
desrespeito eu vi agora transformação
queria falar de vida de
Olá boa noite meu nome ali na hora e o
26 anos e geminiana geminiana geminiana
Entenda como quiser e da Copa do Mundo
ao menos pedir e falar de amor eu queria
falar de paz eu queria falar de
e eu queria falar com saudade eu queria
que ela de carinho sabe queria falar de
Êxtase eu quero falar de dinheiro eu
queria fazer esse curso beleza agressiva
eu queria falar de responsabilidade
emocional mas só dói
é mas só pesa e dói mas dói
e eu queria falar de amor eu queria
falar de saudade aqui atrás carinho mais
doi doi doi eu queria falar eu pensei
que falar de vida de desocupação de
respeito mas já vara babão já Babau
jaraba pau já barababum banheiro ai dói
no peito em alma dói Parabéns faltar no
pulão corta sangrar furado me pega me
joga e me prende debaixo me deitar me
cheira quebrar o coração me de lá a
série inteira eu não vejo razão Eu só
sinto que dó
E aí
e não pega sinal mal dói dos pés à
cabeça falta não é
e corta sangrar furar e pega me joga me
preenche barra me deitar Sheila Cabral
coração me de lá sério entendeu não vejo
razão eu já disse que dó
e eu não quero falar só de bolo mas dói
demais
ei ei eu eu já disse que dói e eu não
quero falar só de dor mas dói demais dói
demais dói demais ai boy eu já vi esse
que dói e eu não quero eu não quero
falar só de tomar Boy nós dois mais dois
demais dói demais Eu já e não quero
falar sobre dor
é mas dói semelhante a minha não se
calava palavras xingava Obrigada e não
se cobrava contrário nos meus contrários
estão brasileiro por isso que estivesse
MM suas melhores utilizar a nossa amiga
lá ainda quando ele me calar me
influenciaram esses mais jogar um
privado em matar esses gritos os velcros
canson me trazem a verdade as novidades
e eu amo essas roupas essas línguas e as
a língua afiada sendo a uma pronta para
cuspir fiz eu tirei você mas não acerto
confio nela mas não acerto Brasil nele
mas só certo assim ele vai ter o acerto
pode ir lá vai ser o certo aqui o sol
bateu a certo ele vai ter o certo Deus
eu vi
e eu realmente não quero que termine
assim para mim e para nenhuma das minhas
por favor não aplaudo
E aí
[Música]